[Musique]
il ya plein de raisons moi je dis
j'affirme que génération prend au
sérieux cette élection et on la prend au
sérieux et plusieurs manières d'abord on
a un programme politique a été élaboré
au niveau européen c'est déjà
opérationnels dès le 27 mai les
lendemains des élections européennes
deuxièmement on dit nous allions nous ce
sera à gauche et seulement à gauche avec
les écologistes
enfin on a un candidat la présence de la
commission européenne yannis varoufakis
l'ancien ministre grec
on annonce donc la couleur aujourd'hui
l'europe et surtout pas social du tout
je prends un exemple très clair que je
n'ai qu'une minute à l'autre ligue
européen ce serait un moyen de tirer les
législations vers le haut sauf qui a
deux propositions celle de la république
en marge
sauf que le smig européen qui proposait
50 % du salaire médian qu'est ce que ça
veut dire pour la france par exemple que
le smic se situerait à 880 euros que ce
sera une cible sans doute qu'il est
évidemment ne descendront pas mais que
le patronat utilisera pour dire que vous
voyez vous prenez partout tiger 50% du
salaire médian de caen france et 880
euros ça veut donc dire qu'on a un smic
beaucoup trop cher nous propose 60 % du
salaire moyen
ça veut dire 1350 euros est impossible
non
[Musique]
la droite mais aussi l'extrême droite
légalement il n'y a pas que la gauche
la question que doivent se poser les
électeurs c'est qui sommes nous sûrs
qu'il respectera une fois parlementaires
européens les engagements qu'il a pris à
part et qui sommes-nous sûrs que la
boussole qui proposera bas montrera le
nord puisque les nuits d'ô est censée
montrer les noirs en clair quel est le
vote 100 % à gauche 100% écologistes
dont on ne doute pas qu'une fois élue au
parlement européen il respectera les
engagements pris devant les citoyens je
pense que la garantie est la plus solide
et la plus fidèle ces générations qu'ils
offrent aujourd'hui
[Musique]